You must have seen a variety of magnets around
you.
A Bar magnet and a
horseshoe magnet are something that most of
us know about.
Apart from these
two, a cylindrical shaped magnet, a ring-shaped
magnet, and a spherical
magnet are a few more types!
But these are not the different TYPES OF MAGNETS.
These are actually
different SHAPES of magnets.
So how do we classify magnets into different
types?
One of the ways in which we can classify them
is based on their occurrence.
That is whether they are naturally occurring
magnets… or maybe artificial or
manmade magnets.
Almost all the magnets that you will ever
come across including the ones we
saw are artificial.
So what are natural magnets then?
Lodestone is the strongest naturally occurring
magnet.
It is black in color and
was the first magnet ever discovered!
Some other naturally occurring magnetic materials
are pyrrhotite, columbite
and even basalt has some magnetic properties!
But these magnets are much
weaker than lodestone.
There is one more way in which magnets are
classified.
This one simply
depends on how long they remain as magnets!
Yes, the magnets are also
classified into two main categories: permanent
and temporary.
From their names, you should be able to tell
me their logical definitions!
You would probably say that permanent magnets
remain as magnets forever
or for a very long time!
And temporary magnets remain as magnets for
a very
short period of time!
These are okayish definitions but not proper.
So what are the proper ones
then?
Okay, here we go!
The magnets that retain their magnetism in
the absence of an external
magnetic field are called permanent magnets.
Their magnetic strength never
really fades on its own!
And the magnets that cannot retain their magnetism
or retain it for a very
short time are called temporary magnets.
Temporary magnets act as magnets
only while they’re within a strong magnetic
field!
Don’t worry we will understand these definitions
in detail in the next video!
But before that, let’s quickly review what
we learned!
Based on their occurrence, magnets are classified
into naturally occurring and
artificial magnets!
And based on how long they retain their magnetism,
they
are classified into permanent and temporary
magnets!
And there’s one
important relation here that we should know
about!
All the naturally occurring magnets are permanent!
Yes!
We will continue
understanding more concepts in the coming
videos!